pop acidulée
ne tombez pas dans le panneau
le ton est pas dans le panneau vous
trouvez comment luc ferry à part la
coupe
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien ses cheveux
comme ça vous plaît c'est petit ça ça me
plaît bon c'est sûr parce qu'elle a
quand même refusé marcello mastroianni
marlon brando à robert de niro et donc
vous elle vous trouve bien bon espoir
luc ferry dont vous avez été pendant
deux ans ministre de la recherche de
l'éducation des universités de la
jeunesse jusqu'au 31 mars 2004 où vous
avez été remplacé par françois fillon
qui a beaucoup de problèmes en ce moment
lui aussi un marpa fillon est plus
facile de changer le ministre que les
syndicats ça c'est vrai que c'est une
vitre et voilà alors aujourd'hui ben
vous raconter votre expérience de
ministre dans un livre plaidoyer où se
mêlent le récit de votre aventure et
quelques réflexions philosophiques
ça s'appelle comment peut-on être
ministre c'est publié chez plon
alors
on va prendre les choses au début de
l'arrivée quand vous arrivez comme
ministre mais par vous êtes plein
d'enthousiasmé formidable rester
enthousiaste pendant les deux années
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un métier
si j'ose dire vase et peut-être pas un
métier mais une fonction passionnante
messager pas perdu l'enthousiasmé manaf
un oui au départ quand vous arrivez vous
êtes très content vous vous dites ça va
être formidable et plein d'idées et on
attendait il faut être honnête on crève
de trouille aussi parce que je suis
quand même pas fou je savais bien que
c'était un métier de chien que saleh est
extraordinairement difficile j'avais vu
quand même les manifs soul claude
allègre ou sous françois bayrou et je
savais bien que serait pas une partie de
plaisir mais c'est vrai que j'avais un
vrai enthousiasme parce qu'ils avaient
des comment dire des dossiers que je
connaissais qui m'intéressait sur
lesquels je pensais pouvoir faire
quelque chose voilà finalement non on va
voir laurent un peu plus compliqué que
ça mais c'est entièrement faux
non tout n'est pas négatif laurent non
mais c'est pas cela est très difficile
sur la place des morts c'est la fille
ont ils se marchent pas là en ce moment
1 rosenau il s'en fait sentir bien
plutôt parce que je crois que c'est la
première greffe qui lasse pas énorme un
an quasiment un an c'est plutôt pas mal
non alors vous découvrez rapidement
étant ministre luc ferry que les
démocraties sont moins gouvernable que
ne le pensent les citoyens et vous dites
au fond les hommes politiques n'ont pas
beaucoup de pouvoir d'ailleurs la preuve
c'est que les grands problèmes sont sont
jamais réglé on ne fait que les
repousser devant comme ça comme un
bouvier quoi c'est hubert védrine qui me
disait l'autre jour n'avait ce débat sur
la question de savoir si les hommes
politiques ont du pouvoir ou pas il est
le métier politique c'est comme un
chirurgien qui devrait opérer un petit
garçon très malade avec un toute la
famille autour de l'ensemble de la
presse 3 les avocats de la famille et
quatre tous les confrères animé commencé
par une haine vigilante et quand ils
vont dire attendez il a la main qui
prendre qu'est-ce qui fait et donc c'est
un peu ça c'est vrai que c'est devenu
très difficile je pense pas que les
journalistes ou les hommes politiques
soient à égalité sur la question du
courage ou l'est où les grands patrons
je pensais la même chose tout dépend du
taux d'exposition qu'on a aux
emmerdements pour être humain
c'est-à-dire notamment pardon aux médias
alors c'est vrai vous dites tous les
français sont d'accord pour qu'on fasse
des réformes
sauf quand ça devient négatif pour eux
dire que la personne veut faire de
réformes oui on est un peu comme des
enfants chez le dentiste quand on l'a on
n'a pas envie d'y aller on sait bien
regarder la réforme des retraites moi il
fallait que j'annonce à un million de
collègues parce que pour moi les
collègues c'est quand même les
professeurs qu'ils allaient en gros
travail et trois ans de plus pour gagner
après la même retraite alors que
pratiquement la moitié d'entre eux
n'avaient qu'une envie c'est plutôt de
partir trois ans plus tôt en gagnant
plus d'argent donc cédé durant ce nouvel
vous pouvez pas annoncer ça même si
c'est absolument nécessaire et en même
temps avoir des gens qui vous sourit ou
qui sont contents de ce que vous leur
dites donc ça c'est aussi le métier
politique c'est être capable d'annoncer
des choses qui sont pas toujours
agréables pour ça que tout le monde vous
dit tenez bon courage au début c'est
même inquiétant quand on lui dit tenez
bon courage vous dîtes surtout quand on
retire les chaînes en même temps que ce
sera paul peut arriver aussi
alors vous dites c'est encore plus
difficile d'être ministre quand on vient
de la société civile
vous dites parce que le président ils
préfèrent des professionnels qui lui
doivent tout qu'un mec qui arrive de la
société civile qui doit rien c'est vrai
qu'on est des électrons libres on peut
dire n'importe quoi dans une émission de
télévision risque rien en plus de ça
parce qu'on est plus courageux que les
autres c'est parce qu'on risque rien
d'une certaine façon c'est bien qu'on va
après votre et notre métier tandis qu'un
type qui a fait ça pendant 40 ans ou 30
ans et qui sait que sur une grève il
peut perdre son job et devenir n'importe
quoi après et il va évidemment être
beaucoup plus prudent que nous c'est
normal en même temps il ya un truc
entendait inciter civile qui est
terrible c'est que au bout de deux ans
on s'en va c'est quand on commence à
apprendre le boulot mais ça c'est un peu
un peu dommage
enfin ça fait partie du jeu et notamment
alors autre problème c'est terrible
quand on lit votre bouquin on n'a plus
du tout envie d'être heureux d'être
ministre parce que notre problème
les coups bas c'est à dire quel
adversaire évidemment les coups bas de
l'adversaire d'hier en fait jacques lang
vous reprocher une loi dont il avait été
l'auteur d'une certaine façon mais j'ai
défendu pendant un an devant des
étudiants qui étaient parfois c'est
assez opposées en fait des arrêtés qui a
été signé par jack lang en avril
2002 juste avant que je n'arrive et
c'est vrai que pendant ce temps là ils
tiraient à boulets rouges mais ça ça
fait partie du jeu aussi ça me c'est
difficile parce que d'une part il ya les
gens qui sont contre vous comme jack
lang et puis vos amis qui vous savez la
planche comme bayrou vous à vous à
savonner la planche 0 1
non mais attendez bées roux qui vous
savez la planche quand même énorme
d'abord parce qu'il est dans la majorité
présidentielle
et ensuite parce que c'est le parrain
d'une de vos fils qu'un énorme
bayrou est un grand discours sur la
réforme des universités
mais pour dire que je suis en train
d'américaniser l'université de
privatiser l'université ce qui en gros
le discours des étudiants dessus donc
vraiment de gauche alors qu'il est 100%
d'accord avec moi sur le fond et il le
sait très bien
quand même été mise des universités
dossier par coeur bon en même temps
comme ils détestent chirac et qu' il a
qu'une envie c'est le gouvernement de
raffarin se casse la figure et que moi
je réussisse pas là où il a peut-être
pas non plus réussi en tout cas pas à
faire ce qu'il voulait il peut pas faire
autrement que tirer quoi c'est pas qui
tire il tire je repasse par des tirs sur
quelqu'un qui dans son dans son propre
camp et qui en plus est le parrain de sa
fille pire que le showbiz mais je les
raconte pas par méchanceté c'est pas du
tout le but du livre il s'agit pas de
régler des comptes mais c'est pour
expliquer pourquoi
oui tout à fait en effet pour moi c'est
impossible en dise politique autant
c'est mal racontée mais c'est vrai
mais vous allez m'aider chéramy deux
fois ce qui est le plus terrible que
tout ce sont les capus ce sont les
campagnes de presse alors c'est
extraordinaire vous raconter par exemple
cet article du canard enchaîné
on dit que j'avais une nurse à moi mes
filles oui tu te fais longer on le sait
alors dit on dit je suis pas au biberon
j'en suis au sein mais enfin on dit que
la soeur de votre femme habite à la
maison suite au ministère vous avez fait
des travaux d'aménagement dans la
cuisine c'est vrai ça mais non c'est ce
qui est en phase 6 est vrai quand même
cirque on a eu un vrai dégât des eaux de
l'électricité à péter parce que le la
résidence du ministère qui était un
endroit sublime sa partenaire à rubis
rosa qui étaient là en vivant au bureau
et qui a donné son nom pour des raisons
qu'on peut imaginer aux grandes poupées
brière qui a dans les brasseries
parisiennes sa vision ses reviennent les
grands poivrier s'appelle des rubis rosa
vous savez pourquoi
non je ça n'est pas infini compris à
quoi tu as des ronds dans ta cuisine les
repousser pour le sel et puis à la
literie en satin aussi voilà c'est une
arme c'est s'annonce terrible c'est que
c'est un peu si c'était parce que marie
caroline votre épouse est devenu un peu
comme marie-antoinette quoi c'est à dire
que d'un seul qu'on lui reprochait des
trucs tijd alors cette literie en satin
surtout on est devenu un peu pas un peu
paranoïaque en fin de parcours mais
comme disait woody allen on peut être
paranoïaque y avoir des ennemis est plus
compatible et donc c'était un peu les
deux premières fait un bon ça c'est
anecdotique mais en même temps sur la
literie en satin luc sérieusement alors
la c1 pour baiser mais franchement
non moi j'ai une façade s'accroche mais
enfin bon chacun face à des draps
c'est ridicule on en convient grosse
équipe dimanche c'était vraiment bas
c'était un cadeau de mariage n'a pas de
sens mais alors surtout comment ça peut
se retrouver dans le canard enchaîné
vous dites mais refaire les gens sont
fous en plus c'est surréaliste parce que
par exemple j'ai eu pendant trois
semaines des papiers sur le thème les
ferries roule en rolls au lit par la
seule voiture au monde dans laquelle je
sois jamais monté il se trouve que c'est
la rose faisais mon père avec vous ma
vitre si je me tais toi c'est pas gentil
s'il y avait la rolls y avait aussi
libération qui parlait de vos costumes à
5000 euros
voilà sa abaissé la voilà on a eu tout
ça mais c'est vrai que derrière le côté
complètement anecdotique et sans aucun
intérêt de cette affaire finkielkraut
avait eu une très jolie phrase je trouve
à propos de la sphère clinton il avait
dit je ne savais pas que la presse
mondiale elle et élire domicile dans le
slip de benfica c'est un petit peu ce
qui nous est arrivé toute proportion
gardée si j'ose dire
mais ces crèmes désagréable pour honorer
ce qui est terrible effectivement moi je
connais un petit peu votre votre
parcours
on a écrit que vous étiez un héritier
que vous étiez un brillant normalien
alors que vous venez d'un milieu
relativement modeste père était
mécanicien automobile de génie certes
mais était quand même un mécanicien
automobile s'était pas quelqu'un qui
avait calé une fortune
vous avez passé votre enfance à traîner
dans son atelier à la garenne colombes
et vos études vous avez fait votre bac
par correspondance
donc dans le genre héritier c'est vrai
qu'à mieux quoi je veux dire ah oui
c'est ça c'est aussi une chose avec
laquelle il faut apprendre à vivre
c'est-à-dire la distorsion complète
qu'il ya entre l'image qu'en donne
parfois de vous et puis la réalité fax
il est bon je vais pas refaire
misérabiliste puis tout le monde s'en
fout mais c'est vrai que si on savait
que par exemple quand on n'allait pas de
salle de bain quand même dans la maison
où j'habitais qu'andré tes mots et donc
quand les jambes présentait comme ça
honneur monde un fric et qui qui
retirait l'argent aux malheureux
professeur et je suis j'étais un prof
exactement comme les autres alors plus
fous de joie le jour où j'ai passé la
grecque et que j'ai vu que j'étais reçu
enfin j'ai tout ça je les ai vécus comme
les professeurs quand on dit que vous
nous les en rolls quand on dit que vous
vous êtes mariés à saint tropez
alors vous avez jamais rouler en rolls
si vous êtes mariés à paris vous vous
répondez aux journaux à ce moment là la
vérité que c'est quand vous faites un
communiqué 1 on vous croit pas mais deux
vous informer tous ceux qui étaient pas
encore fait c'est un désastre absolu il
faut pas il faut pas d'ailleurs de dire
à chaque fois je disais ça encore la
semaine dernière luc ferry a accumulé
les bourdes et les maladresses au
ministère mais qu'est ce qu'ils
appellent des bourdes et des maladresses
c'est simple quand on a le malheur de
dire la vérité c'est tout mais c'est ça
qui est terrible parce que vous
apercevez que quand vous parlez pas moi
j'ai jamais eu de plumes au ministère
personnes écrivait mes discours 1 et
pendant un an j'ai pas eu de directrice
de la communication
et si inimaginable que j'ai je me rends
compte maintenant qu en effet j'étais un
peu barjot alors vous apparaissez
effectivement aux yeux des gens à ce
moment là comme une espèce
d'aristocrates coupé des réalités du
peuple ce que vous n'êtes pas au fond
alors c'est là que c'est là que jacques
chirac vous lâche alors un jour vous
êtes bien alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que vous êtes avec
le conseiller de chirac
ça c'est sur les questions de diversité
l'éducation et caetera et et vous
recevez le journal le monde et le titre
c'est l'elysée à jour le projet de loi
ferris universités il le mec était le
conseiller de chirac pour ces sujets là
qui vient doit lutter au courant non et
c'est un type très honnête très
intelligent pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé et d'affection et je crois
sincèrement qu'il ne m'a pas menti et
qu'il n'était pas au courant donc comme
j'étais à l'elysée j'en ai profité pour
faire ma petite enquête tout le type me
disait mais non c'est une blague du
monde encore les journalistes qui
racontent n'importe quoi maintenant
là il avait tout à fait raison de jours
après 1 en effet je le raconte dans le
livre j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone du
président de la république qui m'a
demandé en gros de faire passer le
projet doit tout de suite ce qui n'était
pas possible ou bien de l'enterrer
définitivement ce qui était plus
faisable mais que j'ai beaucoup regretté
cela dit vous ne m'entendrez jamais dire
de mal de lui parce que je déteste
l'ingratitude surtout c'est pas parce
que j'ai peur de la rétorsion c'est
parce qu'au contraire il peut plus rien
faire maintenant si j'avais des choses à
lui dire fallait
avant les bons choix qui se passe entre
ses 30 ans un métronome
40 de moins de 35 ans formidables
sérieusement oui si c'était à refaire
c'était à refaire à part accepté le
poste de député que que sarkozy vous a
proposé à un moment vous avez dédaigné
un petit peu à part cette erreur là
c'est à dire d'avoir une légitimité
sortie des urnes qu'est-ce que vous
referiez pas pareil je pense que là
l'erreur que j'ai faite à coup sûr c'est
de ne pas faire en sorte d'avoir
suffisamment d'autorité ou de pouvoir
pour pouvoir dire non à des choses que
je trouve est mauvaise
et oui maintenant peut-être quand on a
appris comment dire quand on n'est pas
un vrai politique si vous riez fouette
honnête j'espère un vrai politique mais
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas suffisamment de
pouvoir est en fait vous savez je savais
même pas ce que c'était qu'un officier
de sécurité où un chauffeur donc on
apprend mille choses en mai maison et
franchement dire non au président de la
république sur elle s'est passé pas fait
c'est d'ailleurs même les vrais
politiques
honnêtement le taux de servilité au
conseil des ministres
oui même assez élevé vous raconter sa
life autres vous le dites ça c'est
extraordinaire dans votez vous dites les
gens sont d'une servilité jean louis xiv
à côté on souhaitait de saga la versa et
débutants parce que
à part francis mer qui au début on
sortait enfin parler normalement kouame
mais il s'est fait reprendre quand même
en est on est un peu un peu terrorisé au
conseil des ministres et même les vieux
pros même ceux qui ont fait de la
politique pendant 30 ans ils peuvent
toujours vous raconter ce qu'ils veulent
après aurait un conseil mais quand quand
le président est là c'est très calme
sérieusement lucrèce que votre
principale erreur ça a été de
sous-estimer le poids des idées de 68
dans ce pays parce que d'abord je veux
dire je n'ai fait aucune erreur qui est
ensuite ouverte avec la chemise bleue
mais la cravate rouge après ses
camarades
non c'est pas du tout ça que j'ai dit
j'ai une chose qui a rien à voir avec
avec l' influence des soixante huitards
sur le système éducatif vais vous dire
exactement c'est que quand vous voyez
que depuis les années 20 il ya indique
le faramineux de la maîtrise de la
langue par exemple dans les années 20
puisqu'on a eu la chance de retrouver ça
c'est quand même passionnant dit mills
copie de certificat d'étude des années
23 24 qui avaient été corrigés il y en a
on a refait passer la dictée dans les
mêmes conditions à des élèves du même
âge et en gros pour aller vite
à l'époque ses cinq fautes vous en
souvenez aller au lycée quand on était
petits c'était cinq fautes 0 c'était est
talonné sur les performances des élèves
aujourd'hui ces 17 fautes mais quand
vous regardez la copie 17 faut en
moyenne pour des élèves de 5e 10 % des
meilleurs d'entre eux quand vous
regardez la copie ça ressemble à du
texto et donc moi je disais une chose
simple ans et que s'ils voulaient dans
l'éducation il ya à la fois bien sûr une
part de spontanéité et c'est bien
encourager l'imagination des enfants et
tout ça mais il ya aussi une part
d'héritage dire que vous n'avez pas ni
vous ni moi inventer la langue française
pas inventé la poudre lui non plus si la
poudre la poudre peut-être je sais pas
laquelle mais enfin la langue française
les hymnes on a les yeux
ça roule en rolls et stationnement et sa
seconde défaite mais voilà est donc dans
dans la foulée dans l'éducation depuis
trente ans on assure valoriser la
spontanéité l'expression des enfants
mais en matière de règles de grammaire
la spontanéité c'est jamais très bon et
donc on a oublié qu'il y avait aussi des
transmission d'héritage et de patrimoine
qui supposait une attitude qui est pas
celle du mois je mais l'attitude du
respect à l'égard de traditions qui sont
transmises alors depuis que vous n'êtes
plus ministre
à part bragg et claudia cardinale bravo
d'ailleurs redit avant que cela
marcherait jamais quand on a droit canon
vous êtes au conseil d'analysé de la
société
ça correspond à quoi ce truc là et soul
et c'est un petit peu comme le service
société d'un grand hebdomadaire c'est le
même principe mais j'ai réuni des gens
qui sont pas des commentateurs de leur
métier ou de leur discipline mais qui
sont des acteurs par exemple bon il ya
pour le sport il ya david douillet c'est
pas un commentateur du judo et vos
garanties pour arriver là où il a été
enfin deux fois champion olympique
champion du monde et c
il faut aussi une immense intelligence
les gens qui sont dans ce conseil
d'analysé son ami s'en sont très bien
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font à quoi ils
sélectionnent les bouchons de radiateurs
de russie pub tout je vais vous dire
j'ai observé une chose c'est qu'en gros
à peu près la seule réforme qu'on est
vraiment réussi à faire passer quand en
tout cas j'étais dans ce gouvernement
c'est la réforme des retraites et je
disais tout un que c'était très
difficile parce que en gros on avait ces
comme le dentiste conte avec des
mauvaises nouvelles à annoncer bon et il
fallait le faire quand même je crois est
d'ailleurs en gros le parti socialiste
n'avait pas autre chose à proposer c'est
aussi pour ça que c'est passé mais ce
qui a permis malgré tout de convaincre
c'est qu'il y avait eu avant des comités
de compte des conseils des comités etc
qui s'étaient réunis et d'une certaine
façon les élites notamment
journalistique savaient qu'ils n'avaient
pas autre chose a fait ça c'est très
utile
on a besoin si on veut un jour proposer
des vrais
réforme que au moins la partie éclairée
de l'opinion publique soit formé mais
donc il faut pas se moquer des comités
théodule parce que souvent ils font un
très très bon boulot
enfin vous avez une sonnerie et les
berbères il est quand même de mauvaise
foi problème
alors voilà le livre s'appelle comment
peut-on être ministre luc ferry
[Musique]
maintenant que vous êtes plus mini
souris nous dire à quoi ça sert un
ministre alors en gros ça peut préparer
les réformes que fera peut-être son
successeur le principe de base c'est à
bosse beaucoup et oui enfin ça dépend
lesquels mais parce qu'il ya des
ministères très différents mais dans un
ministère comme le mien honnêtement
c'est 18 heures par jour 1 18
oui oui c'est bien payé
non c'est mal pays voulait que je sois
vraiment unir mais on a supprimé
vraiment les fonds spéciaux et les gens
me demandaient toujours ça mais est ce
que bon temps ils menaient bon d'accord
on est à dix à la télévision c'est pas
vrai maintenant à bien comme une petite
pièce non il ya plus de fonds spéciaux
il faut savoir que cela atteignait
quatre cent mille francs par mois et
donc ça hein van ministre en fait ce qui
veut donc tout ça a disparu
j'ai toujours arriver trop on sait
combien un ministère il s'est payé
combien 40 50 60 francs parce que
c'était moins le premier traitement
était encore en france étaient 78 mille
francs ben voilà attendez à un grand
patron et ans il gagne combien lui et ça
marche ça marche ça marche avec les
filles d'être ministre ça donne un
séjour
je suis marié avec la femme la plus
belle du monde
quand on est ministre on peut mettre
quelqu'un sur écoute
non non non enfin peut-être là je sais
pas il faut demander où les allez rire
mais le mythe de l'intérieur sûrement
mais ça c'est très très réglementés
enfin l' affaire mitterrand c'est
complètement impossible maintenant avec
vous c'est plus à sortir et sari à
l'époque
est ce qu'on doit à l'époque on savait
que ça vous êtes de droite en tout cas
j'ai pas honte de dire que je n'ai
jamais voté à gauche et que je répète
ministre d'un gouvernement de gauche
parce que son tir et un côté très
fâcheux aujourd'hui c'est que les gens
de droite sont toujours hyper
culpabilisés par la société un surmoi de
gouvernement il faut dire les choses
honnêtement je suis centre droit c'est
pas original suit pas et n'aura droit
qu'à faire un test si vous êtes de
droite ou de gauche
oui je vous aime répondre par oui ou par
non envers le cdh sur sa droite ou pas
est ce que vous trouvez lui que vous
payer trop d'impôts
oui non oui oui est-ce que vous pensez
que seuls les forts survivront et que
c'est très bien comme ça
non ça non est-ce que vous pensez que
les gens qui sont au chômage après tout
c'est de leur faute quoi non plus ça
c'est complètement idiot il ya un tas de
pneus en forme il est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faille interdire la consommation
du cannabis
non la joie mais non non faut pas
l'interdire car on pensait contre la
drogue avaient toutes les drogues si
c'est pas pareil
même le vin même le vin alors non le 20
mai c'est pas de la drogue les a
justifié la vessie pétards luc ferry est
ce que vous êtes absolument contre le
mariage des homosexuels
oui oui est ce que vous êtes contre
l'adoption d'enfants par dés couples
gays alors curieusement non avant vous
êtes contre le mariage mais pour la
voiture
en vérité vous avez le droit je trouve
connaître pas mal le problème pour avoir
adopté moi même un enfant sans être
homosexuel mais attendez on alloue
droite pas l'être la semence jugera
monsieur
continuez si j'ose y ajoutant une perche
qui est tellement fait suer c'est
vraiment sur quel le dire voilà je
aujourd'hui vous avez le droit d'adopter
un enfant sans être marié donc vous
pouvez parfaitement adopter un enfant en
étant au mot c'est la leçon lilian donc
ça n'a pas de sens d'interdits est ce
que vous pensez luc ferry qui a pas
assez de policiers dans les rues en
france
non la différence entre un car de
fliquer une bonne lessive c'est que dans
la lessive ya un agent actif
c'est ça le problème
pardon dans les centres
je veux dire c'est la case et qu'une
famille les amis des traits par des vans
moi je vais je sais la mort de mon
commerce
le nord écrit des bouquins est ce que
vous êtes favorable à la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune
or le non j'ai pas d'idée là dessus
ouais si tu as une idée mais tu te sens
bien que tu peux pas le dire ici en tout
cas je ne paye pas et je regrette donc
non il n'a pas la rolls la wii est ce
que vous êtes heureux luc ferry que le
pauvre alain juppé n'est pas été trop
lourdement condamnée par les juges
oui j'en suis plutôt content mais c'est
quelqu'un de très honnête donc c'est pas
jeanne lopis vous savez si j'avais
commencé la politique comme ça par
hasard quinze ans plus tôt j'aurais été
dans un système où par définition
personne ne pouvait être à l'abri de ça
et fonctionnel c'est tout donc on a
assaini le système après peut-être qu'il
avait un petit retard à l'allumage
après l'assainissement du système quand
même les gens ne savent pas de quoi il
s'agit ça veut dire qu'il y avait des
types qui était à la mairie de paris qui
était payé par la mairie de paris alors
qu'il travaillait dans le parti
politique bon c'est pas bien non enfin
c'est pas non plus ne l'a pas tué une
vieille dame a fait pire que ce à quoi
s'est pas c'est pas et en plus il est
quand même condamné enfin il est pareil
quand même très cher attendait ce qu'il
a vécu pendant toutes les années où il
est mis en examen et condamné après
celle en faire un
vous pensez que les français sont une
population d'assistés vous sinon est ce
que vous êtes contre la délivrance
d'héroïne pour limiter le trafic pour
limiter le trafic ou voilà je sais pas
trop ce que ça veut dire comment je suis
c'est à dire qu'en moyenne de l'héroïne
aux gens pour éviter qu'ils achètent des
dealers aux enfants pour les fidéliser
sauna non lâche enfin vous parliez tout
à l'heure du canal du succès un autre
problème héroïne donc je crois que c'est
vraiment une saloperie oui vous êtes
favorable aux mesures contre les
prostituées et leurs clients
je suis pas enthousiaste de la chose
mais n'ont fait pas enfin comment dire
il faudrait distinguer deux choses il ya
le problème des raquettes sur des du
fait que vous avez des réseaux c'est ça
que vise à nicolas sarkozy de prostituée
qui viennent de l'est qu'on force à se
prostituer et on leur dit si tu te
prostitue pas je vais flinguer ton père
ou ton frère
ça c'est ya rien eu des glaces au monde
mais la évident quand vous êtes client
est bon vous participez un truc qui est
immonde mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
plus vieux métier du monde qui est
peut-être pas bien mais qu à rien avant
ça c'est autre chose donc moi je suis
pas là dessus pour confondre les choses
même si c'est pas ma tasse de thé moi
j'ai jamais été très bon mais ce que
vous dites c'est que vous n'êtes pas
pour les prostituées qui viennent de
l'est mais pour les autres ça va quoi je
suis bien je suis celle qui viennent des
gens intelligents cherche à vide complet
de bonne foi on s'est excusé l'ouest
c'est moins grave d'accord vous trouvez
que jean pierre raffarin et bel homme
pour dire on vous répondait on vous a
posé la concession non aller en fait le
nom et sympathie qui lui est cher mais
pas bel vous toucher sa bosse des fois
ça porte bonheur qu'est ce que c'est que
ça k o dia
je les avais déjà touché la base de
jean-pierre raffarin ça porte bonheur il
est pas beau il est pas beau c'est
panard l'ombre en donnons nous crois que
ce serait une solution de rendre les
entreprises plus flexible en favorisant
les licenciements rapide
oui oui là si je suis honnête oui je
pense que c'est un traitement social du
chômage ça n'a jamais été la solution
vous soyez normal comme emprisonne
quelqu'un qui sifflent la marseillaise
bon non vous aimez yves duteil moi j'ai
joué un quart d'heure de guitare avec
lui à était adore sympa il est clair que
les manches avec un petit peu
le combat de josé bové vous trouvé ça
ridicule c'est grotesque oui c'est un
boulet mes pages de ces bovins lors il
est sympa moi je n'aime bien moi non ils
l'aiment pas acheter trouve intègre
moins courageux théorie teint de peau
mais on espère son agent là ils étaient
méprisés lifeco là on a vu son visage
qui transparaissait non n'ai pas de
haine mais n'est pas ma tasse de thé
pile côté comme ça et on dira pas qu'il
est courageux quand non pas du tout
non non pas du tout parce que là tant il
rafle la mise à chaque fois installés
les gens qui ont l'air courage qui rafle
la mise en termes de médiatisation à
chaque fois ça m'exaspère un peu pire
qu'il ya des petits dérapages
comment dire vrai 10
voilà quel papa très clair je ne me gêne
pas du tout cette mouvance là que je
trouve assez politiquement suspect ça
commence par josé bové avec les
moustaches ans à la gauloise sympathique
et ça se termine par tariq ramadan je ne
vois là concis que les gens mais dites
moi alors dernière question et c'est la
plus importante est ce que vous
porteriez des mocassins et des
chaussettes blanches je crois qu'il a un
je crois qu'il ya aucun problème donc
alors le score et 2 donc
donc ils seraient plus de gauche que de
droite finalement je comprends que
chirac les vieillards
peut-on être une
c'est un nouveau jeu avec des gars
attention de vue en vie un vêtement a
pas mal à
j'ai toujours refusé dans les 150 films
de me déshabiller mais j'ai pas le faire
ce soir combien un vêtement
voilà votre école voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai bien fait c'est toi tu dois
dire vous êtes mal barré vous devez
choisir un invité et l'embrassé
e
c'est quand même c'est quand même très
chaste 1 je vous ai connu dans certains
films un peu plus et on ne plaît sans
recommande alors toi et moi si tu veux
j'accueille luc ferry
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
messieurs comment ça va c'est ici
regardez sa pire mais ça commence quand
mal ça commence sympa ouais vous
regrettez pas pu être ministre de
l'éducation nationale non bon et honnête
non non mais cela dit je regrette pas
d'avoir été non plus à dégraisser le
mammouth un peu avant de partir je
crains que la bête soit restée en l'état
personne n'est parfait
ouais puis en plus vous avez vu ce
qu'ils vous ont succédé ils ont pas eu
plus de chance que vaut un oui c'est
vrai que je m'aperçois que j'ai une
longévité assez assez remarquable
puisque les autres ont giclé aussi s
darren fillon qu est-ce qui mène un nom
un an et c'est que maintenant j'ai plus
qui sait maintenant c'est qu'ils sont
méchants quand même a alors été arrêté
et catherine barma me dit dans
l'oreillette gilles de robien
bah oui je le comprends et perben mois
ils se ressemblent un peu à l'écart des
amoureux c'est bizarre avec des morceaux
favoris la croix saint mich
vous savez ça nous la montre est ici son
troisième 100 donc ils sont pas liés les
trois comme ça non y'en as tu savais pas
ça car c'est pas les deux bords il a
deux souhaits et inquiets la barre et
oui c'est vrai il l'a montré en d'une
image dans la tête là pour équilibrer
lacunes
[Applaudissements]
voilà tous deux célibataires vous n'êtes
pas célibataire mon chien noël est là à
côté caroline absolument là vous
surveille non non mais enfin n'est pas
loin quand même invité la mairie
caroline viens viens
c'est pourquoi
en vain
roy
[Applaudissements]
rose et son départ
[Musique]
vraiment est dans le coin elle est à la
maison et elle garde les enfants
voilà la peine à une femme aussi je lis
on l'inviterait plateaux télé ça va très
bien très bien
et alors dites-moi commencé depuis qu'il
est plus ministre vous avez tout à vous
alors c'est bien oui je n'avais déjà
tout un mois ouais ouais et alors
partager un peu il n'a pas souffert de
cela non pas du tout non et bien ouais
et vous êtes tous matin aux castes c'est
quoi le casse c'est une chose qui
s'appelle le conseil d' analyse la
société sts à matignon avec auprès du
premier ministre c c'est en fait très
sympathique parce que j'ai la chance
d'être entouré d'une trentaine de
personnes personnalités de la société
civile ça va david douillet à danièle
thompson en passant par des historiens
des chercheurs des biologistes des
médecins et on travaille sur les
questions de société par exemple le
prochain rapporte qu'on publie c sur les
cellules souches bagages
je peux changer vos places va bien ne
vous mettez là parce que je oui parce
que sinon c'est quoi marie caroline
c'est pas bien avec moi et des questions
sexuelles après la météo la mer si
fabienne voilà tous les deux on regarde
les champagnes garder comme ils sont
beaux là
[Applaudissements]
bien alors vous publié chez plon
un livre qui s'appelle apprendre à vivre
qui est un petit traité de philosophie à
usage des jeunes générations
alors ma fille tu vas suivre là parce
que normalement tu dois arriver à suivre
il l'a fait pour sa fille elle a quel
âge elle avait 12 ans à l'époque donc la
voirie fier
alors qu'est ce que la philosophie on a
quand même temps une heure non mais moi
je vais te le dire la philosophie celle
outre réponse à l'angoissé des hommes la
première étant la religion évidemment et
c'est un salut sans dieu la philosophie
voilà c'est ce que vous dites dans votre
livre c'est assez lumineux c'est assez
simple comme définition alors ça paraît
idiot mais j'ai mis trente ans à
comprendre vraiment ça et et l'idée que
je développe dans ce livre et qui me
permet de raconter à des gens qui n'ont
jamais fait philosophie vraiment
l'histoire la philosophie en rentrant
quand même à fond dans les grands grande
vision du monde
c'est l'idée que on part évidemment tous
d'un certain nombre de peurs on a des
valeurs qui sont ça peut être les peurs
qu'on a devant un personnage célèbre
quand on vient d'un milieu modeste ça
peut être les peurs qu'on a quand on a
des phobies par exemple c est ce que l
état au guide des toques n'importe
et puis il ya une grande peur qui nous
malgré tout qui nous anime tous c'est
évidemment la peur de la mort pas
simplement la sienne mais surtout
souvent la peur de la mort des autres
des gens qu'on aime et cette question là
on n'en parle pas beaucoup la cache
souvent mais les grandes religions ils y
ont répondu elles sont des civils et des
doctrines du salut avec dieu elles vous
disent au fond mais tu n'auras plus peur
si tu te mets dans la main de dieu que
tu te laisse porter par la croyance et
la croyance
ça veut dire aussi la confiance et les
grandes philosophies moi je vous dis une
chose ça n'est rien d'autre qu'une
tentative de répondre exactement la même
question sur comment se débarrasser de
la peur et nos temps de la peur de la
mort avec l'idée qu'on ne peut bien
vivre que si on se débarrasse des peurs
mais essayer d'y répondre sans faire
appel à dieu voilà autrement dit non pas
par la foi mais par la raison alors lu
que vous racontez les cinq grands
moments de l'histoire de la philosophie
et c'est assez intéressante parce qu'on
voit bien l'évolution humaine tiers que
vous commencez avec la philosophie
antique alors la naissance de la
philosophie en fait sénat
en grèce au vième siècle avant
jésus-christ qu'on appelle le miracle
grec et jusque là les religions détenait
le monopole et là c'est la première
recherche rationnelle donc vous dit sans
doute parce que la cité avait une nature
démocratique c'est ça oui parce que la
démocratie est là elle a engendré chez
les chez les humains aux graisses cette
volonté d'argumenter de démontrer
d'essayer de d'échanger des opinions et
par conséquent la philosophie est
certainement né en relation avec cet
univers dans lequel on avait pris
l'habitude de débattre de discuter
encore une fois d'argumenter est donc
d'essayer de comprendre le monde et de
répondre à cette grande question du
salut par la raison plutôt que par la
foi et la première grande réponse
philosophique à la question de la peur
de la mort et comment s'en débarrasser
c'est la réponse des grandes visions du
monde qui sont développés à partir de
peut-être le premier grand philosophe
parménide qui est qui et le philosophe
qui va dominer la pensée avant platon
jusqu'à jusqu'au grand stoichkov jusqu'à
françois valéry qui disait et non
aimons-nous vivant alors il ya un truc
moi qui m'a surpris c'est que la
philosophie antique donc grecque est
assez proche du bouddhisme finalement
parce que l'essence du monde c'est
l'harmonie c'est le cosmos les grands
mots si la nostalgie et l'espérance il
faut vivre l'instant c'est très
bouddhiste non attachement aux
possessions aux biens de ce monde
absolument
est ce qu'est ce que la philosophie
grecque a inspiré le bouddhisme vous
croyez pas ce que c'est la même chose
non je pense qu'ils se retrouvent sur
des grands thèmes et vous avez tout à
fait raison de dire s'il ya une très
grande proximité entre la philosophie
stoïcienne en particulier et puis le
bouddhisme vous explique ça en deux mots
les grecs en particulier stoïcienne ils
vont ils imaginaient que le monde
ce qu'ils appelaient le cosmos en grec
ça veut dire un ordre simplement était
comme un organisme vivant que tu sais
quand un physiologiste ou un médecin
ouvre un organisme vivant
il voit que tout est merveilleusement
bien fait que les choses sont à leur
place quand vous regardez un oeil c'est
incroyablement bien fichu les poumons
tout est merveilleusement bien fait et
les grecs s'imaginait que l'ensemble du
monde était cet ordre qui était s'était
offert un gros êtres vivants si vous
voulez et le but de la philosophie
c'était deux choses c'est tout simple 1
comprendre cet ordre le contempler
essayer de comprendre comment il marche
et 2 trouver sa place
sa juste place à l'intérieur de cet
univers merveilleusement ordonné
magnifiquement fait et quand on avait
trouvé sa place dans le monde comme le
cosmos pour les grecs le monde était
éternelle eh bien on s'apercevait d'une
chose très importante c'est que la mort
n'était qu'un passage et qu'au fond
c'était une transformation d'un état en
un autre et ça permettait justement un
peu comme dans le bouddhisme de vaincre
cette peur primaire qui est la peur de
la mort et donc le but de la philosophie
c'était un de comprendre le monde de
dossiers ajusté c'était tout l'art à
l'e3 pourquoi et bien justement pour
vaincre la peur de la mort pourquoi le
christianisme a t'il vaincu cette
philosophie grecque parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas aristocratique et on se
rend compte que le christianisme en fait
c'est l'invention de la démocratie
c'est-à-dire l'égalitarisme dire tous
les êtres humains sont égaux alors les
grecs avaient en effet l'idée que le
monde était hiérarchiser qui avait nié
rares chine naturel des êtres il était
dans un monde aristocratique ce que la
morale chrétienne va inventer qui est
génial qu'on voit dans la parabole des
talents dans l'évangile en particulier
c'est l'idée que comment dire
la dignité des êtres humains ne dépend
pas des talents naturels du fait qu'on
soit excellent parce qu'on peut être
très fort on peut très beau on peut très
intelligent tout ce que vous voulez
comme talent naturel mais on peut en
faire le pire usages qu'ils soient
l'idée c'est que c'est que en gros la
dignité d'un être humain ne dépend pas
de ses talents naturels au départ ça
c'est la vision aristocratique du monde
mais la dignité d'un être humain dépend
de ce qu'il en fait de ce point de vue
là on est tous à égalité quelle que soit
la base de départ ce qui compte c'est ce
qu'on va en faire et là d'une certaine
façon en effet les chrétiens invente la
première morale démocratique c'est la
première mort à nous nous sommes tous à
égalité à la sens du monde
aristocratique l'esprit est plus
importante que la lettre c'est à dire
que jésus défend la femme adultère
malgré la loi
et ça c'est génial parce que moi je suis
pas chrétien mais franchement si j'avais
un livre à emporter sur l'île déserte
j'emporterai l'évangile de jean et en
particulier je trouve cet épisode qui
est vraiment relisez le colisée le ces
magnifiques parce que dans le texte vous
savez c'est la femme adultère elle va
être lapidée donc il ya tous les types
qui sont là qui vont la lapider et dans
le texte vous voyez le christ qui se met
en deux
du cercle des gens qui vont lapider
cette femme et il se met à jouer comme
ça ils jouent avec le sable et c'est
symbolique du fait qu'ils se met en
dehors de la loi de la cité pour essayer
de faire valoir l'esprit et dit aux gens
au fond mais attendez vous vous apprêtez
à lapider cette femme est regardée en
vous même
est ce que vous êtes vraiment meilleure
qu'elle est les gens se prennent à
douter
et c'est là qu'est la fameuse phrase que
celui qui n'a jamais péché c'est d'abord
le jette la première série évidemment en
fait quand on relit ses textes à la
lumière de cette ce fil conducteur qui
est la question des doctrines du salut
ça devient absolument clair et fascinant
et on comprend pourquoi en effet la
morale chrétienne a vaincu pendant des
siècles mais il ya aussi une autre
raison c'est que l' avantage du
christianisme c'est la résurrection
c'est à dire qu'on dit aux gens non
seulement vous allez mourir il est
ressuscité j'aime chance votre âme
enfin votre corps va ressusciter c'est
exactement les gens c'est que au fond ce
que les grecs promettait c'est qu'on
allait vaincre la peur de la mort en
s'apercevant qu'on était un petit
fragment de cosmos qu'on était un petit
atome de l'univers bon c'est déjà pas
mal mais franchement quand vous aimez
quelqu'un vous n'avez pas envie de le
retrouver comme fragments de cosmos vous
avez envie de le retrouver avec sa tête
que vous aimez bon sens voudrait avoir
des garanties si c'est pour revenir
comme acariens dans la chambre du pied
voilà ce que le christ va promettre et
c'est en fait la seule religion qui
promet ça les juifs ne ne promettent pas
les musulmans ne le premier pas
il ya beaucoup de théories de
l'immortalité de l'âme mais ce que le
christ va promettre c'est la
résurrection des corps est alors évident
les gens se sont demandés mais attend on
va remettre mais avec quelle tête à quel
âge c'est un vrai problème est la
réponse du christ au fond pour le dire
simplement c'est la réponse suivante on
va renaître avec le visage de l'amour
cirque la tête qu'on a aimé vous
souvenez quand je pas des gens sont
morts vous souvenez du visage qu'ils
avaient quand vous les aimez et c'est ça
que vous allez retinne super promesses
en même temps là bas ça a marché
moi j'y crois pas mais je trouve ça
quand même très très beau c'est dur d'y
croire mais c'est dur d'y croire et bien
mariés qu'un mini croit par exemple mais
moi je n'y crois pas il ya un schisme
dans le couple attend heureusement sinon
on s'ennuierait mai
alors on continue on continue lui après
après le christianisme bien l'humanisme
alors là c'est la révolution
scientifique copernic newton des cartes
galilée et l'homme prend la place de
dieu à on est on est on est dans un
monde finalement du bien commun de
l'universel qui se passe autour de la
révolution scientifique en gros entre le
16ème 17ème 18ème siècle c'est que à la
fois le monde ancien le cosmos des grecs
cet ordre merveilleux que je décrivais
tout à l'heure il va s'écrouler pour un
tas de raisons qui sont compliqués que
je vais pas raconter là et en même temps
la naissance de la science moderne va
faire peser un doute aussi sur la
religion de l'art en particulier sur la
religion chrétienne et donc les humaine
cette époque là ils vont se retrouver
sans aucune réponse à cette fameuse
question du salut et donc ils vont être
obligés d'inventer une nouvelle réponse
c'est la fameuse phrase de pascal le
silence de ces espaces infinis m'effraie
les parce que le monde qui était comme
une maison qui était une petite niche
que les grecs habitait eh bien il a volé
en éclats sous les coups de la science
moderne et ils vont re fondé à la fois
la science la morale et de nouvelles
doctrines du salut sur l'humanité au
fond ça va être nos droits de l'homme
gardé une façon ce avec l'humanisme
moderne et c'est aussi évidemment une
très très grande réponse aussi à la
question du salut alors ça ça a été
longtemps indépassable jusqu'à là
qu'arrive nietzsche il est post moderne
celle là c'est le début la
déconstruction
parce qu'une fois que vous développer
l'esprit critique ce que la science va
faire elle va développer l'esprit
critique puisqu'elle va critiquer les
visions ancien du monde elle va
critiquer les religions est donc cette
science elle va développer un formidable
esprit critique mais c'est comme l'acide
ça s'arrête pas facilement l'esprit
critique une fois que vous avez lancé la
machine critique
eh bien on va aussi critiqué les grands
idéaux que l'humanisme avait construit
les droits de l'homme la démocratie et
nietzsche il a une phrase merveilleuse
il dit il faut que les idéaux apprennent
ce qu'il en coûte d'avoir des pieds
d'argile
c'est à dire des pieds fragiles et il
dit moi je vais philosophie au marteau
c'est ce qu'il appelle la déconstruction
déjà et il va casser ce qu'il appelle
les idoles ou les idéaux de la
métaphysique classique pour se dire au
fond le message de la philosophie c'est
d'abord de déconstruire toutes les
illusions consolatrice temps les gens
dépressifs c'est pas à conseiller
vous dites parce qu'ils étaient très
amoureux d'une femme merveilleuse tels
que beaucoup de gens ont compté mais qui
est elle ou salomé qui parait-il était
absolument sublime on était un peu fou
et nietzsche parce qu'il la rencontre un
soir à rome et il la demande en mariage
il a en comptera neuf heures du soir et
la demande en mariage à 11 heures donc
évidemment elle lui dit non mais deux
heures ce qu'on est là elle un peu la
trouille si ce qu'est ce que tu fais un
peu transpirant pas très beau qui va me
sauter dessus donc mais après ils
emmènent en voyage il ya des lettres
magnifique où il dit qui voudrait bien
lui raconter à quel point sa philosophie
et comme de l'acide à quel point il est
des constructrice à quel point ils
cassent les illusions et les réponses
faciles à la question du salut mais que
comme ils l'aiment vraiment il hésite à
lui faire du mal parce que c'est vrai
que sa philosophie est terriblement
corrosive que oui mais en même temps bon
c'est une philosophie absolument
magnifique aussi est faux de l'examen et
le sourire ça aujourd'hui la philosophie
contemporaine poursuit le travail de
déconstruction entamée par nietzsche
elle tu sers lacan foucault deleuze
derrida
alors c'est vrai qu'à la différence de
l'époque des lumières aujourd'hui on
peut penser que on va vers le mieux car
ce qui est mort aussi je la notion de
progrès
ce qui s'est passé si vous vous laissez
pas tellement que le progrès est mort
vous savez bien tous ici que chaque
année nos téléphones portables sont plus
performants et même si vous regardez la
médecine des choses plus sérieuses ça
progresse tous les jours mais ce qui a
changé par rapport au xviiie siècle
c'est que au xviiie siècle en était
convaincu encore dans l'humanisme que
nice va critiquer que le progrès allait
finalement que le progrès des sciences
aller à la fois émanciper les humains et
les rendent plus heureux et est ce que
ce que nietzsche va évidemment kcc cette
croyance au progrès cette croyance naïve
et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui là où il
a d'une certaine façon raison c'est que
bien sûr nous progressons tous les jours
en un sens sur le plan technique mais
plus personne n'est absolument certain
que le progrès est un progrès donc on
n'est pas absolument certain qu'on est
plus libre et plus grenat des retours de
qui concerne par exemple tu vois il ya
des trucs qui vont pas et donc on a le
sentiment que bon d'accord on va acheter
des voitures plus performant des
téléphones portables publiquement mais
que c'est pas forcément
plus de liberté plus de bonheur donc il
ya un progrès mais en même temps la
vraie crise du progrès c'est la question
est ce que le progrès est un progrès et
coire et personne n'en est absolument
certain c'est ça qui va finalement être
le grand ébranlement du 20e siècle
attention l'homme est il responsable de
tout ce qu'il fait oui hélas tout
pouvoir s'accompagne t-il de violence
non suffit-il d'être poli envers autrui
pour le respecter
non mais c'est vraiment un premier pas
important la nature fait elle bien les
choses
non il ya laurent baffie entre autres
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien suffit-il de constater pour
atteindre la vérité non pas du tout la
liberté se définit-elle comme un pouvoir
de refuser en grande partie oui notre
liberté de penser at elle des limites on
va te donner
[Applaudissements]
peut-on être libre sans être responsable
non suffit-il d'être dans son droit pour
avoir raison non plus la morale
s'apprend tel un tout petit peu pour
beaucoup l'amour peut-il être un devoir
non surtout pas elle somme vient de
perdre ses illusions
oui quand même peut-on être sûr d'avoir
raison
non les différences sont telles des
inégalités non non bien sûr que non
la liberté consiste t elle à faire ce
qui nous plaît non plus la recherche de
la vérité peut-elle se passer du doute
non plus peut-on rester un philosophe en
venant la télévision oui évidemment et
enfin ce que sucer c'est tromper
aïe aïe aïe alors la dernière fois
j'étais à côté d'une jeune femme
charmante j'ai tiré un truc c'était
embrasser votre voisine donc il arrive
vous devez dire du mal de votre films ou
livres au disque tombeau cas que d'aller
en moins oui je veux dire du mal c'est
vraiment moi qui les crises éclairage
chez les hommes politiques mais
l'annoncé la bd louis marie caroline est
alors descendu mal pour voir
rami avant dire du mal moi j'ai la
chance de vivre avec un homme qui m'a
tout appris justement qui m'a appris
qu'il s'ingénie donc
merci
est ce que l'amour rend aveugle encore
philosophie parfois oui ça les rues
c'est un génie sous les gens quand on
est bien tous les deux
elle est pas mal non mais je suis
toujours amoureux - rennes a fait la
joie était pas mal non plus tu sais
qu'au bas c'est gentil at war mais bon
philosophe
[Musique]